withdrawal was a catastrophe in my
opinion
and there was an inexcusable lack of
accountability and negligence America is
building a nasty reputation for
multi-generational systemic abandonment
of our allies that we leave a smoldering
human wreckage from the mountain yards
of Vietnam to the Kurds in Syria
our veterans know something else that
this committee might do well to consider
we might be done with Afghanistan but
it's not done with us
if we don't set politics aside and
pursue accountability and Lessons
Learned to address this Grievous moral
injury
on our military community and right the
wrongs that have been inflicted on our
most at-risk Afghan allies
this colossal foreign policy failure
will follow us home and ultimately draw
us right back into the graveyard of
Empires where it all started